les alliés de l'Ukraine parlent d'une
voie commune le prix du pétrole russe
qui transite par les mers frappe à 60$
le Barry dès lundi
ces trois objectifs selon la présidence
de la Commission européenne sont de
renforcer les sanctions diminuer les
revenus russes et stabilisés le marché
énergétique mondial
après des semaines de pourparler la
Pologne qui souhaitait un plafond moins
élevé c'est finalement rallié au groupe
malgré les conséquences économiques des
sanctions pour l'Europe
l'Occident et solidaire
par rapport à l'inacceptabilité de la
guerre en Ukraine
concrètement cette sanction est possible
parce que la Russie dépend largement des
occidentaux pour le transport maritime
de son pétrole même si les destinés au
marché chinois et indien les pétroliers
et les assureurs basés en Europe aux
États-Unis au Canada et en Australie ne
pourront plus transporter le brut russe
au-delà de la barre des 60 dollars
une fonction trop timide aux yeux du
président helenski puisque le brut
s’échange à 65 le Barry seulement
quelques dollars au-dessus du plafond
annoncé c'est sans compter que le
pétrole russe voyage majoritairement
parlait au duc je ne pense pas que ça
ait un impact immédiat et
majeur sur le déroulement de la guerre
en Ukraine le Kremlin assure avoir prévu
le coup et menace même de couper le
robinet au pays qui appliqueront cette
sanctions
[Musique]
on va seulement l'acheter à 60 dollars
de Barry 60 dollars le baril pour les
Russes là c'est un prix qui est très
raisonnable l'impact sur les cours
mondiaux sera déterminé par les
prochaines actions du Kremlin mais
surtout par les décisions que prendront
les pays membres de l'OPEP qui se
réuniront dimanche l'effet sur les
marchés soit c'est un inconnu lundi va
marquer l'entrée en vigueur d'une autre
sanction européenne l'embargo sur le
pétrol russe acheminé par voie maritime
qui réduira des deux tiers la dépendance
du Vieux Continent envers la Russie ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal